since its debut a decade ago Dead Rising
has continuously evolved it's changed
settings and protagonists added crafting
in vehicles abandon escort missions and
limited saves in spite of all of these
changes however the core gameplay always
remained intact grab whatever's handy to
kill and maim droves of zombies in a
huge variety of gruesome hilarious ways
Dead Rising 4 maintains this tradition
of superficial yet entertaining mayhem
by adapting ideas from every previous
iteration intrepid photojournalist Frank
West for example finally returns as our
playable protagonist we also revisit
Willamette Colorado which has been
completely rebuilt since the original
outbreak many years prior tragically
it's once again the epicenter of an
undead pandemic only now its citizens
are supposed to be inoculated this
raises a lot of questions for Frank and
his rebellious Protege Vicky both of
whom fight to uncover the truth in their
own ways for game that's all about
mindless zombie murder the storytelling
is remarkably adept Frank and Vic's
relationship feels nuanced and
believable that's my camera yeah it was
hanging in your closet which was locked
not very well the central mystery
consistently meets out new clues that
keep the plot interesting and the action
meaningful and though Frank isn't always
likable he's frequently relatable and
entertaining spouting goofy smartass
quips at every opportunity some
developer there's also a coherent
personality that binds every aspect of
the experience together from the dark
satirical humour of the collectible
journals to the jaunty holiday music
that plays over the pause screen
[Music]
Dead Rising sucks - position of
slaughter and silliness makes for a
memorable world the gameplay on the
other hand is a bit more mixed
fundamentally the core combat has
evolved less than any other facet of the
series though Frank uses a mix of melee
ranged in throwable weapons you're going
to spend most of your time just mashing
the X button to whack whatever's in
front of you it's serviceable even
satisfying in it's cathartic brutality
but it's also rudimentary offering
little depth or challenge in fact Dead
Rising 4 is rarely challenging in any
way I always have plenty of health and
weapons and armed enemy soldiers seemed
nearly as brain-dead as the undead the
new super agile Evo zombies are
definitely harder to put down but of the
14,000 plus zombies I killed only 71
were Evo's what greater mechanical depth
could have made Dead Rising for a more
intense and rewarding game I can mostly
forgive its light combat for two big
reasons first the deep and hilarious
supply of outrageous combo weapons there
are now more than 50 in total and once
you've obtained a blueprint and the
requisite materials you can craft your
new death dealer on-the-fly rather than
dragging everything to a workbench like
Dead Rising 2 whether you've created an
electrified ax or a toy Santa that spits
acid new combo weapons consistently
provide fleeting bursts of a
concentrated joy
the game may not challenge your skills
but it certainly rewards your curiosity
there's also plenty to do outside of
combat unlike the original and its
immediate sequel Dead Rising forest
campaign doesn't have a timer and while
that erodes the series identity to a
degree it allows the open world and all
its activities to really breathe the
central mall and its surrounding areas
are packed with hidden secrets
interesting weapons and compelling
collectables obtaining combo weapon
blueprints frequently forces exploration
and puzzle solving which can be
frustrating but also satisfying you can
also seek out maniacs special side
bosses that never fail to hit you with
an amusing curveball and of course
Franks packing his trademark camera so
photography returns as an optional
method for accruing experience and
achievements it also plays a crucial
role in the arkham esque investigation
sequences that periodically pop up
during the campaign the process of
saving your photos isn't particularly
well explained upfront but having a meta
game that's always available can turn
even random exploration into a
worthwhile endeavor
[Music]
in defiance of the two most recent dead
rising games co-op has been removed from
the campaign and funneled into a
separate multiplayer mode the pacing and
narrative scaffolding of the campaign
work well without a partner but the new
mode doesn't offer much consolation for
co-op fans basically you and your squad
spawn in a slice of the world complete a
series of objectives selected from a
small preset pool then head to a
randomly designated safe zone it's
enjoyable enough but the unimaginative
structure and lack of distinct gameplay
ideas makes the mode feel like a bit of
an afterthought
regardless of what you choose to play
dead rising forest tech holds up well
for the most part I noticed a few
zombies trapped in objects with just
their arms poking out of say a giant
rock
but the framerate never slowed
noticeably which is quite a feat
considering how many zombies could
populate the screen at once Dead Rising
zombie slaughtering formula has started
to wear a bit thin after all these years
especially since its combat remains
largely routine but the surprisingly
well-crafted story wild new combo
weapons and expansive open-world
elements turned Dead Rising 4 into it
over the top piece of popcorn
entertainment that captures the series
best elements
[Music]